but I was supposed to be finished so
yeah maybe yeah so let's just do like
one of the exercises and if there is
time we can just get back to the
exercises at yeah yeah so how about we
do exercise number three has anybody had
has everybody had a chance to look at
the exercises I guess and they got
non-sequential sorry sure yeah so let's
let's even forget about the first part
of exercise 3 that's yeah let's just see
what what we get for bivariate
multiplying polynomials right so the
question is you have a polynomial of
this form and you can also assume
exercise one I guess
so when is such a thing la concave
[Applause]
I mean if you actually write on the has
seen you get the following matrix minus
e square so your I think the Hessian of
the log yes okay so the Sen of log of G
is okay - B squared
- so d squared here C square to the
bottom right BC minus 80 and that's
right
okay so first of all when we are dealing
with a degree two polynomial complete
log concavity is the same as just la
concavity because if you take one more
derivative you get like linear
polynomials for those low concavity is
just trivial right so so you just have
to check that this is you
yeah the constant of proportionality
here also depends on the value of your
polynomial and stuff like that so it's
not a constant matrix but it's always a
positive scalar of this right and you
can again observe that this is a matrix
with a positive trace right so you only
have to check the determinant again to
make sure that the to make sure that
both of the eigenvalues in this case are
positive because you're taking the
negative of this thing so you want both
of diagonal used to be negative right so
you want exactly d squared times C
squared to be bigger than BC - ad
squared so I can just take a square root
of this and I get BC bigger than EC
minus a B which is basically the same as
say
do they feel yeah this should be B yeah
go ahead so so you want the Hessian of
the lock to be negative semidefinite
right so I'm not I'm not working with
the healthy end of my palm you know this
time I'm taking with I'm looking at the
Hessian of the log of my palm y'all
which is this thing times I think or
divided by G or something like that so
trace here yeah if you're talking about
the negative of this matrix the ratio is
negative yes if you're talking about
this matrix without the negative sign
trace is positive and you want both
eigenvalues to be also positive so that
when you negate it the whole thing
becomes negative semidefinite so so
again you can just check the determinant
and you get PC bigger than BC minus ad
and you can also check that ad has to be
absolute value of B C minus ad and this
is equivalent to basically ad being less
than twice PC
okay
so if you remember you had an exercise I
don't know if you went over it or not
but viewing cheyenne stock you had an
exercise to check when this thing
becomes real stable right so it does
anybody remember what the condition for
real stability was so this is this is
the condition you need for being
completely not concave for real
stability you need ad is less than BC so
this already tells you that there are
things which are completely concave but
there but are not real stable so so okay
so the the last part of the exercise
it's an inequality that was first I
think observed by Junie haha Boateng
bank for Metroid's so
so now we want to use that inequality to
basically prove that some approximate
version of negative correlation is
satisfied right so you want the
probability of I and J being in a set s
when s is selected according to a
completely lock and key formula to be
less than twice the probability that my
zenus times the probability that J is
honest
so any ideas on how we can prove this
or that coordinates yeah so if you look
at the gyrating palm you love em you you
can plug in a value of 1 for every
coordinate except for Zi and ZJ and then
the result that you're gonna get is
going to be a bivariate formula which is
going to be of this form so the result
that you're gonna get is going to be of
this form probability that I and J are
naughtiness plus probability that isin s
J is not eNOS times CI plus probability
that I is not in s and J is NS x zj
that's probably that both of them are in
s times VI times EJ
now you just apply that thing over there
and you get actually something stronger
than what I've written over there you
get something slightly stronger than the
negative correlation up to a factor of
two but it implies negative correlation
of the factors so I should maybe maybe
you mentioned that so relax versions of
of negative correlation are something
that patter and juni have have studied I
think that you call it C Reilly or
something like that yeah
so I don't know so yeah so it's a it's
an interesting basically object to study
what you can get just from approximate
negative correlation not completely
concavity all right so so yeah so let's
let's keep the exercises for now and
let's get back to the talk I guess
yeah so now we have completed this
picture we now have a candidate for this
completely la concave distributions so
what I want to show next is that their
supports are exactly metroidlike major
I'd like objects so so what we have
shown so far is that if you have a
matron you formed distribution over the
basis of a Metroid give you a complete
philocan key distribution but I haven't
shown you the reverse right okay
so um so yeah so let me
so the support of a distribution is
always going to be so for now we are you
only looking at homogeneous polynomial
so let's say that D mu is the
homogeneous and it's also multi a fine
and we want to show that basically
support of mu is a collection of bases
of matrix so so to prove this we are
going to use basically this geometric
characterization of basis of matrix so
what is the support going to look like
here the support is going to be on a
slice of the hypercube right so so you
look at basically all this set which is
basically all 0 1 vector is very exactly
they you have D ones right the support
of MU is going to be a subset of this
now there is a geometric
characterization for Venn subsets of
these things become basis of a Metroid
and that geometric characterization is
this that if you look at so the
indicators of basis for all of the so so
look at the indicators of basis when
easiness and look at the convex hull of
this indicator basis so convex all of
these things when B is an element of s
or say
okay it's going to be some polytope
supported and a fine slice of the
hypercube right so every so so so in
this poly tope you're gonna have a bunch
of edges or one dimensional faces you
get an egg you get a Metroid exactly
when these edges are the difference of
two standard basis
so whenever basically B is connected to
so Introit if and only if when b1 is
connected to e 2 in polytope
and the indicator of b1 - the indicator
of b2 is some AI - some EJ inej are
elements of the standard basis
so now one thing that you can show using
this is basically very similar to the
proof that the supports of real stable
palm wheels are mate roads almost the
same so it's not a very innovative proof
but let's just go over it so the point
is that if you look at this poly tope
it's the Newton polytope of your palm
Yeah right if you restrict your palm
you'll and drop the terms that don't
belong to a face so so let's say that f
is a face of this poly tope and you look
at basically the palm y'all mu
restricted to the face which is just the
sum over basically the
you have be easy to the B where B is
inside the space okay so we're going to
show that this polynomial also is
completely la concave for any face no
matter what and when you prove this you
can restrict to a face which is an edge
so when you restrict to an edge it's
going to be of this form Z to the B plus
or Z to the b1 plus Z to the b2 right
when is this going to be la concave you
again need to connect that support nests
for this to be la concave right so let's
say that lets say that b1 and b2 are two
elements such that they're symmetric
intersection is bigger than two if the
symmetric intersection of b1 and b2 is
that is exactly to the difference of
their indicator vectors is exactly the
difference of two standard basis
elements and we are done so let's say
that these are this symmetric difference
is bigger than two now you look you can
look at basically they're so defined
basically C to be the intersection
or if you want the indicator of C to be
the element wise minimum of b1 and b2
now if you differentiate with respect to
elements in C right what you're going to
get at the end is going to be so so
start from this formula this is G of M
you restricted to the face F so when you
differentiate basically with respect to
elements inside see this phone LG muse
of F what you're gonna get is Z to the
b1 minus C times Z to the b2 minus C
added with Z to the b2 minus C right but
unless both of these are of size one
this is a sum of two two polynomials and
the total degree is bigger than 2 so
this was not allowed right the connected
support Ness was not allowed so you're
gonna get something which doesn't have
connected support and it's not going to
be completely not concave
so so okay so all I have to show you now
is that when you have a face of this
polytope if you restrict your power to
the face then complete lock concavity is
preserved right and this is also easy to
show because
so first of all you can basically show
that if you have a transformation going
from RN to RN
and your transformation basically takes
the positive orphans to the positive or
thence
so this is basically a slight
strengthening of the fact that when you
do affine transformations and the input
la concavity is reserved right I'm just
saying that complete la concavity is
also preserved you can just verify that
because when you have an affine
transform when you are taking
derivatives of this you can just apply
chain rule right and just take the
derivatives through so so what I'm
saying is that when you were taking DV 1
up to be VK of so your affine transform
is is always of this form P of X is
equal to ax plus B and a has positive
entries he also has positive entries so
that's what what I mean by the positive
Orton being preserved you can just check
that this is equivalent so when you
apply a bunch of directional derivatives
to basically G ot using chain rule you
can write this as basically partial
derivatives along a v1 up to a VK apply
to G composed with T now if we want
through VK ver elements in the positive
or thence a v1 up to a VK would also be
elements in the positive or sent so this
thing is completely la concave and then
when you when you of course apply a
affine transform under input lock
concavities preserve okay so you can do
affine transforms on the input and
complete lock on cavity will be
preserved now how do I use that to to
prove this I'm going to apply basically
a simple transformation I'm going to
apply so T of Z is going to be
so let's call it this way
so I'm going to just multiply each
variable by some number okay so these
numbers I've represented them in a funny
way as e to the T W 1 up to e to the T W
and what's the point of this the point
of this is
the point of this is that G ot would
become the sum over all u of s Z to the
s times e to the T times the product of
W and the indicator of s okay so that's
how those scalars come out right and now
if you look at a face of your poly tope
there is some vector W so for for a face
f it exists the vector W is such that
the face is basically the arc max of
inner product with W
comics all of this of course
right so so the scanners are really
maximized at the points on the face
right so now if I if I divide the whole
thing by this maximum value and let T go
to infinity every term goes to zero
except for the ones on the face right so
because because completely' concavity is
a property that's closed on their limits
you get the palm you're restricted to
the face
so this is a proof that that basically
the supports of these things are also
metroidlike objects so the so when
you're not multi I find the support is
not a Metroid but it's a basically a
generalized parameter Udrih yeah yeah
exactly I'm glad I was gonna show that
towards the end of his heart okay so so
let me switch gears up a little bit and
so I told I briefly glanced over this
conjecture of Maitre of Mason and on the
independence of independent sets of
Metroid let me just mention that again
so so in the beginning of the talk I
talked about la concave sequences and
how they are prevalent all over
combinatorics one of the one of the
sequences that used to be conjectured to
be la concave but now it's proven to be
la concave is when you take a mate right
em and you look at the sequence of
basically a 0 I 1 up to I to the rank
where ika is basically independent sets
of size key
so it was conjectured to be it was
conjectured that this sequence is la
concave a proof of this was first given
by by the reference here huh suretrend
Bank but there is also a stronger
version of this conjecture which is also
due to Maison which was not resolved by
by this conjecture
so this stronger version says that when
you divide these by binomial
coefficients you still get a lot concave
sequence
so now that we have developed our all of
this theory I think a cool application
to see is that you can easily get this
the strongest form of the Mason's
conjecture and this is exactly what we
did and also better and joined it in an
independent org so so so I showed you
that the generating formula of basis of
a Maitre D' is completely lock on k but
what you can show is that there is a
there's a different polynomial
associated to metroid which is also
completely lock concave okay so so the
pommel is of this form you sum over
independent sets this time instead of
basis you take the product of the eyes
our eyes in the independent set but you
homogenize this to degree n with an
extra variable Y so if you want to prove
the complete la concavity of this thing
you can exactly use the previous
machinery okay
turns out that again you have to only
prove this for Metroid's of rank two and
four matrix of rank two you can just
write down the hessian and observe that
this is the hessian is a rank one matrix
minus a Piercy matrix and everything
works out okay so so once you have the
complete lock on cavity of such a thing
how do you get the ultra lock on cavity
of this sequence so it's a it's an easy
exercise you just plug in the same
variable Z for all of the Z eyes
so so the the bivariate Palmilla you
were going to get by doing that is is
exactly 0 times z 0 y to the n plus I 1
z 1 Y to the N minus 1 up to basically
by rank Z to the rank y to the N minus
rank
and for homogeneous by various formulas
we already observed that completely
concavity is equivalent to the sequence
of coefficients being ultra low concave
when you divide by the corresponding by
the corresponding binomial coefficients
you get an ultra you get a lock on keep
sequence right so that's basically once
you have all of this machinery that's a
one-line proof of the strongest form of
this and this is this is also basically
the equivalent of what patter and June
also did so so why am i showing you this
example this is this is an illustrative
point where you basically see that
this is to illustrate that complete la
concavity is not about the roots so if
you're familiar with real stable Paulo
meals when you are when you when you
have a real stable palm you'll like this
which has a factor of Y right so so you
can just basically factor out y to the N
minus rank which is the minimum degree
with with which Y appears in this form
you'll hear times some other polynomial
in y&z right so let's let's call this
other formula h of y and z right when
you have a real stable for meal and you
factorize it in this way each of the two
sides has to be also real stable right
because when you don't have roots in a
certain region none of the factors can
have a root in a certain region right so
completely concavity cannot be about the
roots because the POW meal here would
not be completely la concave if it was
you would get you would get something
stronger than the law concavity of this
sequence you would get basically the
binomial coefficients with n minus right
or sorry rank replaced where you can
just observe that even for like the
uniform metroid' that's false the
uniform a trade on n elements with rank
rank so so completely lock on K formulas
don't have this property that the new
factor in the mouth each of the factors
is complete without concave and and
that's why this is really just going
beyond the roots all right so okay so
that was I showed you two polynomials
for Metroid's which you can prove are
completely lock on K but of course the
machinery is is there to prove other
things so here are some of the other
things that you can prove are completely
law concave so so something that also
Peter and June showed is that the random
cluster model the so this is a so in the
in the graphical metroid case this is
this is this distribution you start with
a graph you select a subset
and then the probability of selecting
that subset is going to be proportional
to basically some parameter Q to the
number of connected components imposed
by that subset times the independent
distribution so you can think of
basically think of this so sample sample
edges independently of each other each
bit probability P and at the end
multiply the probability by Q to the
number of connected components there is
an analogous thing for general Metroid's
I'm not going to mention it but you can
actually show that this this thing for Q
between 0 and 1 also satisfies complete
block concavity it is a it is a so that
if you're familiar with the taught poem
you love the graphs or matrix this is
basically a transformation of the
top/bottom you exactly so so again the
machinery just boils down to checking
this for Metroid's of rank 2 and
everything so the significance of all of
these is for sampling algorithms which I
won't mention at all today we're going
to see them later on in the semester so
if you care about a determinant of point
processes so here is something that is
also completely lock on key but not real
stable ok
so in a determinant I'll point process
remember that you had like these PST
matrices an alternative description is
you have a bunch of vectors you select a
subset of them with cardinality equal to
the dimension of the space and each
subset you select with probability
proportional to the determinant spanned
by those vectors
a squared so that that distribution is
real stable and it was important in
machine learning because it has this
repulsive property that you you tend to
select vectors which are far apart from
each other ok so now if you if you want
a knob on the under diversity you can
raise this determinant to some power
between 0 and 2 and turns out that for
any any power less than 2 this is going
to be completely lock on key
this is actually true for any other
distribution that's completely la
concave if you start from if basically
mu is CLC and mu raised to the power
beta for theta between 0 & 1 is also CLC
so and this this gives you a knob on the
under diversity this is so this this
goes back to the point that federico was
making so i told you about the multi
affine homogeneous case so the support
of CLC distributions in those cases are
always basis of a Maitre you can ask
what what is the general case so it
turns out that you can reduce everything
to multi affine homogeneous on wheels
I think exercise one tells you how to
homogenize and there are other things
that you can do to make things multi are
fine so if you do all of that what you
get is that the support is always going
to be of this form take basically a
polytope whose vertices are integer
points and whose edges are either
parallel to the standard basis or
parallel to the difference of two
elements in the standard basis so so
these are slightly general a slightly
larger class and generalized parameter
ETA and the supports of the support of
any CLC distribution is going to be of
this form
and moreover the for any polity of of
this form there is going to be a CLC
distribution supported on it so the CLC
distribution supported on this polytope
is basically a truncation of the Taylor
expansion of e to the X so that's that's
the way I like to think about it so if
you look at
so if you look at basically e to the X 1
up to xn this has some Taylor expansion
right by the way this is not a
polynomial but you can see that it's CLC
if you take anybody any number of
derivatives of it and it's going to be a
multiple of itself and then when you
take the log it's going to be a multiple
of a it's going to be a basically a
linear function which is concave right
so so that statement is saying that when
you restrict the Taylor series to a
point inside such a polytope okay so so
sum over yeah I've written it down here
so sum over only point integer points
inside the polytope of whatever you get
in the Taylor series of via e to the X
this thing is completely law concave so
so yeah so when you were talking about
zero on polytopes this is the this is
the generating formula of the uniform
distribution that you're talking about
higher powers you have to including the
factorials so all right so let's so that
was the basically the last fight that I
had I have so I have 20 minutes for the
open problems or should I should we give
a breaker okay that's good so so in the
open problems I might might still
continue a little bit of a lecture but
so there is one open problem for which I
have to explain some things but so
should we just take your five minute
break or yeah
[Applause]